good afternoon let me thank organisers
Martin for affording this opportunity to
give this talk I hope I can manage I'm
still suffering of the jetlag quite a
bit but but anyway let's move yeah
outside simply as follows I have
something about this case regulatory
modules alignment free abroad for
finding them in high throughput selects
data we have been using in my group and
then all finding transcription factor
binding motives the monomeric and the
numeric motives simultaneously from from
this large and rich selection date at
the end I will comment briefly on only a
long distance dependencies within these
motives and how to how to present and
and have some some final comment on
simple representation of these motifs
and finite state machines so we are here
in a Institute of theoretical computer
science of so finite state machine it's
an appropriate thing to consider yeah so
here is a schematic picture of what is
gene regulation no need to comment on
that in this audience too much so a
regulatory module is a collection of
transcription factor binding sites on on
DNA so no no precise definition is
available as far as I know you had the
discussion yesterday night maybe maybe
there was some
convolution achieved then but but I'm
just a simple computer scientist and I
don't have any any good definition just
some characterizations or features of
how how this look like so they they
should consist of several code binding
sites of transcriptional factors these
these modules these sites are especially
clustered together so there should be
some denser area where well there are
lots of these motifs and this is kind of
a candidate for for such a module and
then and they are supposed to be
evolutionary evolutionary conserved
which would lead to alignment based
approach for predicting such regulatory
modules but I'm not not speaking today
on on this alignment based approach but
but just direct learning from from from
signal sequences without comparison
between species here I have a simple and
formalization of this and this module
structure which will not have too much
role in my talk later on but but anyway
this has been kind of an underlying way
of thinking what we have been doing
module has binding sites of factors like
this F 1 F 2 F 3 4 and
each factor motive has a location within
DNA and and each of these motives have
orientation so that they are in normal
direction or reverse direction so the
normal ones are here on above all the
DNA and under this is the reversed here
and now the problem is a given a DNA
sequence predictor regulatory modules on
it and then using this kind of chain
model we couldn't find under some
scoring scheme the best among the
potential change induced by the
available motifs so I come back to this
you know in a minute so as I said a line
alignment based approach is comparative
genomics and and we did some work on
that some years back and that the
resulting tool is called yield enhancer
element a locator which aligned
corresponding areas of our genomes from
different species and until tried to
find them consult sequential patterns or
motive individual motives they're in
alignment tree in a case we try to find
the over-represented precision
transcription factor binding site pairs
in this token and I Marisa
from selects data and we haven't just
finished up a tool which we call Moodle
Scandinavian because the data comes from
your city police laboratory in Stockholm
so so our model is our learning and then
the final goal of all this is combined
this may be hundreds of dimer models in
the scanner that finds in this good
change of heart red it's a good change
of motives along along DNA but I am not
having having any any results of this
yes question is to model the local steps
of regulatory model of our models how to
score the regulatory models and just we
have scores for factor to DNA
interaction and factor two factor
interaction and then and the total score
a chain of individual motives is just a
sum of all like affinities or factors to
bind to DNA plus affinities for
successful factors to find to each each
other so we to use this model we need
both this and this factor to DNA scores
and factor to factor scores
yeah yeah yeah so this is this leads to
dynamic programming and so to make this
converts you need this Carlene out so
conditions so that it is cities maybe
smith-waterman type of dynamic
programming at the end otherwise it is
going to happen just what you said that
it gets longer and longer so you need to
you need both bonuses and and penalties
in these scoring systems to to make this
work so what is happening if we
eventually will we'll be able to use
this is that data from from this
potential provide insights for
individual factors it picks up the best
chain under this scoring scheme then
selects and source all so what I'm going
to talk about mostly is in just and this
individual motive or this is these are
individual steps here but not about this
total thing so selects is a hmm all
already mentioned here several times our
collaborator hidden in this Alexa is as
I mentioned you see you see tybelus
laboratory in in Stockholm and they have
been developing selection protocol where
currently I think they take 14 base
pairs for random DNA and select binding
sequences from balls of this kind of
random samples of uniform samples of DNA
and in several cycles they get
for the given factor that has been used
in this fishing they get reeds that
should have occurrences of the binding
motives for the particular factor in
enriched amounts okay and then this is
this has been over years this has been
improving so I'm not sure if they
already do longer than forty base pairs
but at least we have been using this
type of data and and these selects
generations typically can produce maybe
ten thousand to 1 1 million breeds so it
is really really rich data and quite
different from the situation for for a
de novo motive learning and as compared
to 20 so this is my understanding what
is what is happening if we use them use
let's say in a factor with this type of
affinity and then and then they said
core sequence ta ATC see when it is
counted from the observed reads it has
the highest highest count and when you
go to one humming step away from this
core sequence II the counts are still
high but but not quite as high as this
here so Teresa yesterday killed this
picture totally so so but amate I have
to trust on this map all my work is
based on this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so so
so if this is not true then I don't know
what what sense is all this selects
business business at all but there must
must mum can could be of course some
lilac resistor and under of course there
are lots of our artifacts in deselect
rates that you have to trim over first
from my head this is not based on this
is not not based on any real data this
is just illustration but what I expect
to happen there okay so here here is
some some information what is happening
payant I fell in love alam do they
really have a big factory so so they
have been producing this this selects
datasets for hundreds of factors for
human and mouse right I don't know what
wonder is a bit uncertain for me but but
what is what is also important is that
they also produce not not only forces
individual factors but pairs of factors
which is a which is essential if you if
you want to do really well
optimizing this this chain of motives
along the DNA you have to get some
information
how how likely it is that after this
factor I have this here and at what
distance and then using these pairs of
factors day in the in selecting can
really get this this information how
long what is the spacing
finding is how do you in which you have
in this case a pair of factors yeah III
assume that he he starts with a factor
one first generation the next generation
with a factor two third generation again
with factor one okay so but my guess is
that dissident this pair of factors
thing is not totally symmetric so there
is a first factor and second factor that
might have have some awesome effect yeah
so learning binding motifs from selects
data as we have reached a data we could
could consider many many types of models
what I'm and that the motor Moodle is
doing is just practical position rate
matrices but also also Markov model is
now now possible and not only this
linear spanning tree type of Markov
model but the model Eric was speaking
yesterday where we have a spanning tree
a real spanning tree not only only
linear and then when when you look at
the typical logos quite often it is it
is the case that this is maybe not not
very good example but anyway the the
number of high affinity strings it's not
that that big according to the law so
here here I have sketched a situation or
or this is this is not based on real
name
so this this is a string for example of
course 44 4,000 times in in the data and
here is the listing in decreasing order
of frequency don't just take these
strings as the model so and here is the
representation of these these strings as
a finite state machine where I have
white tier the transitions by the count
how many times this data goes along each
party so this this doesn't generalize
anything but I time allows I have a few
more picture of how this this could
could work yeah so so the the basic
scheme what we are doing is that we we
want to maybe give seeds for for the
monomer models in in the data and try to
learn all possible preferred die america
structures built from these monomers so
so here here is it just how how this
dimer can can happen so so it is so so
that the first head of this is against
the tail of this so it is HT type or the
head of this is towards the head of this
so it is HH type and so so we get this
for four different
arrangements and and all other the
distance D is also I said so leather
baby model distance on-base per
granularity so it is really so here
again this parameterization of dimeric
structures here are two two successive
motives and under had all this is
towards the tail of this so it is HT
type and that is tas between this is
denoted by D and if they overlap then
the distance is negative so then then
what we do especially what the model
here is the deviation from the the pure
modular model where the dimeric models
also in the overlapping case are just
products all the monomers but tybelus
process just recently published a paper
where they studied of course the same
problems and and and and their
observation is that in large number of
primary case is the specificity or
dimeric motives it differs notably from
what would be expected from the
monomeric motives so what we are doing
in motor is it to represent explicitly
the deviation from this pure reduction
to model on america motifs in the
overlapping case of that diamond so so
whatever whatever what we do is it's
just that mixed the mixture model where
probability of a selects read x which is
of length 40 for example and contains
may be many motive occurrences and
motives are typically maybe relate to
13:15 monomeric motifs this is long so
so within just represent the select read
in these three separate cases the
binding site of a monomer occurs in in
the read binding site of a dimer of
course in in a read and the four dimer
we need to know the relative orientation
and under the spacing between the two
monomers in the diamond or X is just
from background so this leads to this
kind of formulation which I don't think
to go through in detail maybe maybe this
is here here is my my correction terms
also this is the for correcting an
overlapping dimer as compared to the
product for the monomer components and
the look likelihood is like this and
then to to to solve this we just follow
the path of meme more or less so views
in algorithm which now launched
simultaneously for each monomer the PBM
and also the spacings and orientations
for the preferred dimeric pairs built
from this
monomeric and we have of course this
mixing a mixed mixture model has has
mixing mixing parameters and these
mixing parameters reveal how popular
each alternative is this is am converges
but to be successful you need it good
the starting point so we use all the the
algorithm needs seeds for for the
monomer models but not for diagonals
sorry pills from this monomers designer
structures we are working or have been
working a long long time already - to
automate also this seeding part but at
the moment we just have to give disease
okay and then here here here is an
illustration of the resulting model for
this factor so so here is the only
monomer model for for this silly one and
here here are the mixing parameters for
all possible dimers that we have a
certain range of this parameters that
can be used so so for example here we
have mixing parameter value point zero
four four dimer that is headed to head
type and has spacing one and this
particular dimer is illustrated here so
it is hit to head and here there is a
between one column that is taken from
the background
and here here is a another example of it
comes from here where the mixing
parameter is point zero four again but
this is overlap over length six and head
to head type so it is this one here and
here here is the correction matrix shown
so that this which is given by the data
differs this much from from the plain
product of this in this position yeah
so as you can see there is a clear
difference is most of these dimeric
cases and do not get too much weight in
this mix mixing values but there are the
in this case we have actually three
quite strong cases two of them have been
shown here then I have some some tests
for the different a few factors we
worked it so this is the same flea one
and this is just to illustrate that
using this combined model where we have
monomer and in this case three dimers
this together gives better squared value
when we count ten verse as scored by the
model and as observed in the selected a
so the this is already individual R
squared here and when we combine using
this mixed mixture
parameters lambda we get the highest l
squared for this and here is another one
and maybe here is a third one where we
got really really strong square that
this factor only has four different
monomers undependable we combined them
they're square at this point 99 so these
were just kind of sanity checks using
the same select data was used for for
learning but here here is an independent
test for cheap sex discrimination and
this Hawke's Bay 13
gets pretty good Rock values for the
individual components they are a bit
smaller than for the combined model and
here is this this it's an F for which
gets really really high rock core value
for or already for the individual
monomers but especially for that
combination so so this resource that is
this make mixing pays off maybe not very
very very much in these cases but anyway
yeah so to close three three okay yes a
few words about how to describe the
affinity landscape hidden in this
dislodge and
selects data so for this our friend age
and f4 we I don't know how how we got
this this seeds but anyway the the thing
we can used for seeds maybe maybe it was
you see table who told these are good
for this this factor but anyway using
the motor we can can find this
collection all for monomeric motives and
then and that no divers in this case
well then this same thing can be
described using Markov model and then
now now under this combines all these
together so that that now you can see
some dependencies which are not not
clear from here so that for example if
you have J T then this C that should
follow etc so as these are I independent
these columns here the the certain
dependence in information is of course
lost so but if I take take this most
frequent 13 mare from the data
it occurs 44 thousand times and go take
its Hamming environment environment of
radius 6 and then pick 23 strings
according to the frequency and represent
them as as a finite state machine I I
get this kind of description photo for
the affinity landscape now you can see
that there are kind of four highways
here
they don't directly correspond to these
four cases but anyway there is some some
some similarity which which I don't yet
understand fully
if this DFA really good could be useful
here in representing these things but
what is important here that all all the
dependencies that are within the the
highly scoring our highly high frequency
strings and this this this thing they
are that they are preserved here there
is no no learning no generalization it
is just as the data says so what I'm
aiming at here is that a motif is just a
set of motif in instances and sketch of
algorithm how this would work and decide
motif lengths find seeds some locally
maximal k-mers in the in the frequency
landscape takes the big most frequent
k-mers in our Hamming neighborhood or
maybe you should allow some some shifts
because the mountains in this landscape
are such as they are use the type allah
calls this neighborhood holding a
neighborhood because his laboratory a
scene in holding a tsubasa board next to
no stop and a representative what you
get as a minimal rated deterministic
automata so this is 4:31 such strings
listed here so the count here is about
44,000 for the highest counting and I
got I got down to two thousand and
you have that once you built the
optometry apply certain sequences must
be able to occur when I say whatever
list of frequencies you get the
frequency count yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
so there are two things combined here so
the automaton is is just a
representation for these two strings
will without any any any role all of
these counts and then later on I I just
eat each of these strings has unique
paths here and III just Kumal eight how
many times they are gone through if but
by the cow so it is that way I think
this come come from third generation
yeah yeah miniature did was for this
this factor they had six 600,000 threes
or something so that means it's like 20
full ratio in town really reflects like
a three fold ratio infinity
yeah so there's a three-fold difference
in infinity yeah yeah this is this is
maybe something like 5% of all days a
discount yeah by more than three four
okay but IIIi was not satisfied with
this only so here here your are are more
of these with different are thresholds
of cutting this things and and you see
that there is some some invariance here
but can can be can we understand what is
the landscape I'm on from this vampire I
don't know so so I should really
simple-minded thing just so this is this
is no machine learning this is just a
representation for this this finite
languages no no no but this is the first
good question how to how to little bit
make this softer so that they they they
work a bit with the larger sets and then
what what what would be the role to do
that but anyway we don't need some some
discrimination exercise with this and
and and you see that this is really as
long as it can score data really really
really gives a very very good order of
course but this is needed to call much
too much larger
automata than what I have here so the
end gives how many strings were
represented there so so so here here I
get 0.9 something as a rope car but it
was already 24,000 Springs represented
and totally unintuitive
so this is this is just using automaton
like this this gives us the scores for
four for each it's strange I was using
automata like this for further
discrimination yeah but this many
strings so I have to stop so yeah the
goal is to make a scanner that combines
factor binding models or as kind of that
takes all four factors together is
likely to don't produce too many false
positives so we maybe we could reduce
the set of factors to be included in a
scanner by using some cell type specific
subsets and no clear song should be
included here automatic seeding is
missing still and then this last thing
if we could maybe instead of BBM's that
lose lots of information use long
dependency models thank you
I'm burnt you good question
we have we have something which they
have published but we have some
unpublished also it is mixture of our
work which I am not totally over oh yeah
our collaboration with title is that we
meet maybe eight times a year and and
try to do over email many things and it
is not always so easy millions of
sequences I'm going to Reza mentioned
yeah yeah yeah we have used very very
good seeds so it converges quite rapidly
yeah and maybe maybe 30 40 rounds
crucial is to have a very good seeds
yeah yeah a dream a dream or or yeah
yeah yeah all right I think what to take
the rest with this guy